hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar covid-19 looking ahead to Winter
2022-2023 and Beyond I am Megan Pascal
of lab roots and I will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by diasaurin to learn more please visit
diasaurin.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Juliana locascio director of
microbiology and biology laboratory
Department of clinical pathology at the
payachanza hospital in Italy Juliana you
may now begin your presentation
hello everybody
I'm really happy to present to my uh
presentation here about kovid and how we
conduct our diagnosis and use of Copic
test in piachenza and what we are going
to expect from the next winter season
um I like to present my hospital is a
hospital that he works in a very big
area uh is about uh 2
000 kilometers
square kilometers more than 250 500 and
uh go to
2087 sorry 287
000 inhabitants it works on three
hospitals one main hospital which is the
one where I work and two doesn't
decentralized and hospitals
we work in um
complete time so we work 20 hours in
seven days and we had
um micro microbiology and virology unit
which work on on bacteriology infectious
serology
parasitology and mycology and
now also a big
part of molecular biology we perform
about seven
hundred thousand tests per year
um
why we are going here to speak about
covid because we know that
everybody knows that during
the first month of 2020
we find a new a new pathology that is
the coronavirus disease 2019
uh which caused a very uh bad
respiratory syndromes called covid 19.
and it has gone to dominate the
attention of many uh all the words so
clinicians researchers and all the
community
and this was because uh
covid-19 represent uh the third a
biggest spillover of coronaviruses in uh
so in last 20 uh years so this enormous
impact is uh
it
involved all the all the world and there
was just
um and experience in 2003 with sarskov
the first the SARS call the infections
and then in
2012 2015 with Middle East Respiratory
Syndrome uh these viruses can spillover
from animals perhaps
there are many studies and on perhaps
from bad to humans and has got a very
fast rate of transmission
um in particular this is SARS Cove II
this is the reason why many passions has
got these infections also because there
was no existing immunity for this virus
um
in these two years we saw more than
450 million cases of the world and more
than 100 million cases were in Europe
This is a respiratory viruses that
um spread in droplets so by respiratory
droplets and the symptoms changed over
the time so it starts with a very bad
pneumonia interstitial pneumonia disease
but it also presents with fever coal for
sore throat and loss of smell and taste
um
this is a
as we we know uh the outbreak of
evolution from 2020 uh since now till
now and
um as we can see there are many many
countries involved so all the globe was
um was involved and uh affected of this
problem this is the wave
um
curve of the curve of the wave of the
outbreak in Italy and as
um as you can see the first wave is a
very little one but started at the
beginning of the uh of the pandemic so
Italy was not able to uh to make the
young this as the other part of the
world
um we have the first case on the 31 of
January 2020 and as you can see this is
the picture of the different waves in
piachenza the hospital where I work
where the main and the the worst period
was just at the beginning because as you
can see you can find uh you can see that
in March 2020 almost all the bed of the
hospital
were full with coveted passions so it
was a nightmare
now uh this is uh the upgraded uh
um situation and as you can see the
admission are really reduced along all
the wave until now
the diagnostic
all the all the world
make a very big effort to rapidly
respond to this pandemic events and uh
that therefore it was enormous in few
weeks many testing approaches have been
employed uh related on local testing
capacity also in piachenza we were not
able to make so many molecular testing
or other kind of uh so a huge number of
tests and
um but the young uses and specifically a
very rapid and early diagnosis was the
the main point to permac to allow
isolation of suspected patients and the
way that the only way to control
outbreak and prevent uh extensive spread
of the disease
um what the the Laboratory Testing was
based on a symptomatic presentation of
passions but it was also done on
screening of asymptomatic people and
also in screening of a particular
um
population that are healthcare workers
what are now looking on we are there is
a great concern uh for next winter about
the need to differentiate between
um covid disease from a seasonal flu
that could clog hospitals emergency
devices and could also slow the
diagnostic for patients with kovid
because we know that they are similar in
presentation and both covered and
influenza viruses can cause lung
inflammation that could
give more sensitivity to other
infections or other pathogen
what are the diagnostic tests for covid
detector we can detect the viruses so
the RNA detected by molecular test PCR
and we can detect also the viral antigen
in a particular many different antigens
main of the most important one is the
nucleocapsody antigen and in the other
way we can look at the immuno response
against covid so how antibodies
um
Reach the the presence and then if we
can look at the in IGM or IGG serology
and this was the diagnostic approach
that was like uh really enormous puzzle
uh based on a clinical feature but also
on a Laboratory Testing
on biological
Laboratory Testing and also on Imaging
but all the these
part of the diagnosis were not specific
so the more specific diagnosis was more
was made by Laboratory Testing in
particular molecular biology that was
the gold standard
but during the outbreak and the pandemic
some things was changed so with the
introduced with the immunity or on of
the people
some part of the diagnosis changed so
now we look uh preferably
moreover on clinical feature and we do
all the lab tests
to make the diagnosis of covet
what about antigens antigens were uh
used
in other infection diseases so we are
used to use it to diagnosis of dengue or
also enable or also in HIV
infections for sarskov 2 the target is
uh nucleic acid protein and the use of
antigen tests in increase
together with the molecular diagnosis
increase of the our power to diagnosis
to to diagnostic for corvid to find also
hidden infections then
a very important aspect of antigen
detections is that could be automated
with the high throughput workflow and
not a very high protein turnaround time
so it's very
quick to to have the result
we also can have a lateral flow essay to
use as rapid tests that could be used in
a specific situation when you have high
numbers and of people which have to be
tested in a few minutes as in airport or
you need to use it in a self-test so
this kind of Diagnostics works with the
um with puct
or also in a lab version
has got
less cost than molecular biology and is
really easy to perform so if we want to
make a comparation between
rtpcr and the antigen test what's
really evident is that the sensitivity
is really different because a tpcr
tests are really sensitive
and the antigen test
moderate sensitivity we can we can uh
see something about that
later and but the complexity is really
different so antigens is really use easy
to use
it's also very fast in 15 minutes more
or less you are the result and the cost
of the test is low
um what are the difference in
sensitivity sensitivity there are many
many studies that
looked at the frequency to test our uh
the the sensitivity could
um
could work better if you
um so our test with a low sensitivity to
our moderate sensitivity could work uh
better if you perform it in a
very very with a very high frequency and
this is the reason why in
um many many
setting antigens were used and
were used
[Music]
um
over
um substitute molecular testing
many Studies have been done and have
been done to look at the sensitivity and
I just present one of these that at the
beginning
looks at the sensitivity of one antigen
system
in our situation we wanted our automated
lab automated test with a high
throughput so we looked at the antigen
that were
that were possible to do in our hospital
and centralized in the lab and we looked
at the antigen do with the liaison Excel
the instrument we we have in our lab and
this study look at the sensitivity as
you see the specific the specificity was
excellent and since positivity was
correlated to the viral present viral
load so if the sensitivity was in this
study 73 percent
but
for example with a CT value of our rtpcr
below 30.
in the same way we looked at other
studies in a particular there were
multicentric Italian study which looked
at the
um
the capacity of virus replication and
residual viral RNA in a patient with
different kind of City level and so
viral load and the conclusion of this
study that involved many italian centers
conclude that
people are no longer contagious when a
molecular Diagon uses is based on high
CT value more than 35 in one gene Target
with
without clinical data so
all together this information so good
um
charitable sensitivity and with the
um CT value
around 30 and
determine the um
the change over the time of the use of
the diagnostic test so here you can see
that in 2020 all the diagnostic on covid
was performed on molecular tests but
during these two years with the
assumption that
antigenic tests could work well
um during the time some kind of
population where
um
um we used this kind of diagnostic so
antigenic test to to see uh if they were
um pyramid or no so uh at the beginning
uh just
um
we work on asymptomatic Healthcare work
screening and at the end so now we
perform a lot of antigenetic tests on
our population our passions
except the frail patients and we perform
also the screening for admission to the
hospital so
um here you can see what happened on a
molecular testing in our
um in our
town at the beginning we start with a
very big effort because there was a not
uh
um
big molecular laboratory but we made a
lot of effort to
structurate it and to do about seven
thousand tests in a week but in January
we reach 12
000 like for for the wave of the winter
of 21
2021
and on um on
July August we reach a very normal
wave with more than 26
000
samples molecular tests done in in a
week but now what happens the waves and
the problems with the admission and with
the recovery of patients with kovid is
is
quite nice so
we reduce
incredibly in the number of molecular
testing
but in the contrary or the what happens
is that
antigenic number of tests grow up at the
beginning we choose to make
screening on healthcare workers because
we
um with that some the assumption that
all asymptomatic people could work and
we looked for the asymptomatic spreader
then we start with the look also at the
symptomatic patient with the programmed
admission and now uh we work
mainly with the antigenic test
um we continue to screen our healthcare
workers but also we looked at the
admission Passions
um each test we choose each test looking
at the the European list of antigen
tests certified and no other tests could
be done in the hospital because we was
the tests which have a clinical
performance approved with the clinical
studies and this is the last
upgraded list and our antigenic test is
also in this list
um what our
direction of the country said uh he said
that the surveillance of a symptomatic
healthcare workers it could be done just
with the antigenic test
um
they divided our healthcare workers into
a big group one high risk area with the
emergency room
personal involved also Intensive Care
Unit
care workers
um can you see also very frail
passionate words like oncology or
hematology or transplant words are in
these big groups they replay the
nasopharyngeal swap each 21 days each
three weeks all the other parts of the
hospital is considered not high risk
area and the care workers
repeat the swab each 30 days
this is the diagnostic workflow we used
because we perform this
chemiluminescence antigen test in
asymptomatic healthcare workers if
Negative they stop and could continue to
work if the
swap is positive we confirm the
positivity with rtpcr and what happened
with the symptomatic one
they
are they go to the center of our
surveillance of the hospital and they
perform a POC T antigen test if it's
positive they stop and go home if it's
negative they confirm it with the rpcr
um another way to use the antigen test
now is the emergency room so the
admission to the emergency room this was
the situation uh until March 2022 where
all the patient went to the emergency
room who need emergency room went to a
very big area where they wait uh until
they know the result of a tpcr
the results were almost
um
um they they have the result almost in a
two hour uh what
um when the result was uh
available uh they were oriented in the
correct word or copied negative or
covered the positive words
now since April 2022
We performed the poct at the emergency
room uh area and they after this 20
minutes poct
make the correct distribution of
admission so for asymptomatic patients
they replay every two days uh their
antigen test for the first week and then
if the patient became cinematic It Go to
rtpcr
this is a graphic of our numbers so if
you see the blue line it's the molecular
test and since June
2022 can you see that decrease the
number of the molecular test and grow up
the antigenic one as we expected with
the reduction of cost and also of
organization in our lab
what about new variants how these new
variants can impact on a diagnosis
new violence are um
some recombination of view viruses that
Express in genetic lineage
which are monitored all in the world
through epidemiological investigation
and
also a surveillance on genetic
sequence
of the variant of the genome
so uh them who
the finder different type of variant
name
we identify the variant of concern which
are the variant which can have a
increased transmissibility and also a
reduction in
natural neutralization by monoclonal
antibody treatment and also which not
respond to
neutralizing antibody we have with the
vaccine vaccine vaccination
so is um is is a problem
on the spread of this kind of violence
another kind of variance is the variance
of Interest which have a specific
genetic markers that predict
predicted how to um Factor transmission
diagnostic or can have the immune escape
this could cause also and
increase or another outbreak and
are going to to be
to pay attention over the spreading of
this virus
other vibrant that could be
monitored are the variant that looked
ought has got a significant and
sustained reduction in proportions over
time like Delta in our
last period
this is a temporal distribution of SARS
called two variants in the world and
also in Italy is uh similar to other
parts of the of our globe and this is
our temporal distribution of different
source code to variance into a chance
and we looked and sequenced into the
viruses along all the periods and uh
since March March 2021 and as you can
see there there was the same
distribution during the time and now we
have uh 100 percent of Omicron in our
country uh with the 93 percent of uh ba
5 5 and other ba4 ba2 in respectivity
and four percent and two percent
what about diagnostic test with this
virus because we have to look at the
[Music]
efficacy of our diagnostic test on what
is the
spreading in our country so this is a
work which heavy danced to how the our
test our antigenic test works with the
Omicron virus which is the main one in
our country and it looked at two periods
as can you can see from this
[Music]
the slide
um
it looked at two period swaps one during
the
um second pandemic wave during uh can
you see 2020 February 2021 and another
wave from January to March 2022 is known
that Omicron
variance was going on so
um they compare
um the the result of the antigenic
license in liaison sarscope to
antigenous a
and see that the overall sensitivity was
the same so the
um
Target the nucleocapsid was not affected
by uh the changing of the variants
um the sensitivity the overall
sensitivity was no so high because the
who asked a sensitivity of 80 percent to
allow a test to be used in hospital this
was
lesser and about looking at the
different sensitivity on City value as
we said
um there since the sensitivity grow up
uh with the CT value that are around 30
or lesser than 30. so it could be a nice
test to identify if people are spreading
or not the viruses
and also the this study and this work
showed how if we changed the cutoff of
positivity we can reach also a very high
degree of
um sensitivity which increased to 88
percent
so you can manage in your own this kind
of information to work and
reach a better sensitivity depends on
your population
another Works make the same and compare
the performance of the nucleic acid
protein
antigen of the the liaison essay
and looked at sensitivity also with the
performance of viral load and say the
same with the CT lesser than 25 you have
around 90 percent of your sensitivity
and 100 of species specificity
so uh the conclusion of all this work
also looking at the different use of
this test with different variants here
they looked at Alpha and beta variance
and conclude that a automatic tests have
the advantages to be
um a good um
a good level or sensitivity and also the
advantage to high throughput screening
possibility
so if we want to look at the future we
can have
um
uh
we have to look at the different
diagnostic tests and to keep a
consideration to the different use of
the our diagnostic test and how a
possibility so if uh now we have many
molecular tests not viral test which
looks at the RNA viral RNA and
they have different kind of
um
possibilities
um capacity to
um to be sensitive so we go to through
um different parts of uh
different uh condition of sensitivity we
can go through 90 up to 90 percent uh
[Music]
for a very very
high CT so as a very high sensitivity
but the in the in the contrary the
problem is how long you can identify a
patient as positive without any
pathology and we also have antigen tests
which can have a high throughput if you
use it in the laboratory uh so you can
centralize it and in 18 20 minutes
you can reach many people with a good
sensitivity just to look at the
possibility to uh of the people to be
the spreading of the Eurozone
uh antigen test could be done also as we
said with the point of care test like
lateral flow and we also have a very
um rapid test in 15 minutes each one can
have the result and also detection of
antibody to look at the possibles now
many people are gone on vaccinations so
the antibody are used to
discriminate between responders and
non-responders
but the uses no so
um
there's no there's no uh um now uh a
high useful test just for frail patients
in this work in this review they
differentiate between the situations so
this is what we have to do in our future
to identify different kind of population
or situation where to use a different
tests and different diagnostic tests so
if we have symptomatic individuals we
can do uh the rtpcr if we have the
position the possibility but we also can
do if
um we want to
discriminate between respiratory viruses
other rapid and mixed
PCR looked at influenza also
respiratories in gtlb resistant
and we can go through the work flow to
use the positive or negative
result to
to go in deep and make a second level
tests in our symptomatic passions but
different is the use of tests on
asymptomatic individuals in particular
if they
have gone to assess to their health care
to the hospitals where you can use
antigenic tests as we do in a pure
chansa and if they are negative leave
the patients go on and no more tests are
needed but if they are positive you can
go in deep and confirm it with a
molecular test
other similar way to use the test is
also for the general population where
you can have a single event where you
need just to know if you are spreading
sometimes
person and you can use also the rapid
lateral flow test to be sure you are
negative
uh what is going on on our future
um we are going to our winter season so
there are many studies and there is a
concern about what happens in the other
hemisphere about influenza in Australia
they see a very high number of flu
patients and this is of concern or
because
we estimate that the next winter
there could be uh 10 or 10 to 60 percent
or increase of sociatability
um because the lockdown limited the
um people have um contact with influenza
viruses so this is the first winter we
have uh the probability to to reach uh
and to to have contacted with influenza
viruses so uh the epidemic could up
upgrade could be
important and this is why we started a
very active program on influenza
vaccination
but we have also
um the
we have to improve our diagnostic test
as we do here to
explain to emergency room to
um to perform uh
um and not a start a complete study and
to look also if a symptom if a
symptomatic passions come to the
emergency room to perform
um what we go what he called the
surveillance of influenza all in all the
country and we looked if there is a
respiratory symptoms look at covid
influenza and erespu
RSU
contemporary with mixed
molecular testing
so I go to my
last slide
um so we have we have to know that now
we have got many available tests and we
have to use it according our
epidemiological data and our logistic
and organic and Hospital organization
we have to announce surveillance testing
especially in a symptomatic passions if
they have contact with hospital to
reduce the virus spreading them and this
is mandatory in healthcare workers and
caregiver
uh we also need to differentiate between
uh
respiratory syndromes between viruses
respiratory viruses so we
um we
um
we want to
um
perform many many Diagnostic in our
future on differentiate between this
kind of viruses and to find if there
will be mixed infections because this is
the um the concern of our government
uh we have also to look at the economic
impact of the diagnostic workflow
because now we are paying a lot of uh
all the the money we used for the
outbreak in our country so
um our chief and economical Chief asked
us to look at the uh the use of our
economic resource but we haven't to stop
the molecular diagnostic because it's
the base of
surveillance and also is mandatory the
use of molecular test to monitor the
emerging of new variants and we ask over
our government to implement sequencing a
capacity over our lab
I want to
thanks all the people who work with in
my in my lab and which
contrasts the spreading of the viewers
each day thank you
thank you Juliana for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located at the far left of your screen
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for let's get started our
first question is which is your
experience using saliva as a different
Matrix to detect SARS Cove 2.
I've got experience with a saliva Matrix
we use data especially for children at
school to make surveillance in piachenza
schools but the test worked well to find
to to reach and to find a negative
negative children about
many many of that were negatives perhaps
because the the period was not so
um was not an epidemic period so there
were very few cases in piachenza so we
abandoned the use of saliva test
great thank you our next question is how
is your point of view on self-testing
for SARS Cove 2 detection
as we know saliva self-testing uh no so
sensitive uh as a laboratory so I ask
people if it's possible to perform
laboratory tests
because there are many issues on
self-testing that you have to to to to
think on so the um
system if you if you do your how
self-test it is not sure you perform a
correct test because you have to go uh
in deep your nose and this is not easy
to do some other one have to to uh to
sample your nasopharyngeal
secretion and
but I know that is uh well
um
is is friendly used
in house this in-house test so is
very
easy and friendly for people so you have
to to balance these uh this this point
so they are no so sensitive but many
people used and perform
um I hope and
self-isolation in my country the
government
um
permit allow the
um
registration of the result of the
self-testing in the database
also to count numbers of self-tasting a
positive people at home so they permit
also the the use of this this test at
home but I prefer lab tests as I am a
Laboratories
great thank you and our final question
for today is how do you see the
evolution of covid-19 diagnosis
uh the evolution is trade rapid so I
think we are going on an endemic
um
covet like like other cold like other
coronaviruses so the evolution of the
diagnosis could be related just on
symptomatic Passions
great thank you so much
thank you again Juliana for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank labroots and
our sponsor diasaurin for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we'd go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
they're interesting questions questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of your registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye